auch die entschuldigung gegeben vom
bundespräsidenten vom bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten und auch von der
innenministerin nancy faeser
da kommt er jetzt sagt herzog kommt nun
in den deutschen bundestag und wir
schalten jetzt live über nach berlin
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident herzog sehr
geehrte frau herzog
sehr geehrter herr bundespräsident
sehr geehrte frau büdenbender
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler
sehr geehrter herr bundesratspräsident
sehr geehrter herr präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichts exzellenzen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
verehrte gäste
die weltgeschichte kennt kein beispiel
für den vernichtungsfeldzug den das
nationalsozialistische deutschland gegen
das jüdische volk geführt hat es ist
keine sühne denkbar für die vernichtung
des lebens dieser millionen von
unschuldigen zitat ende
diese sätze wurden vor 70 jahren nicht
gesagt als das luxemburger abkommen
unterzeichnet wurde
der israelische außenminister mosche
schadet verzichtete auf die
vorbereitete ansprache auf bitte
deutschlands
konrad adenauer war das abkommen mit
israel eine moralische pflicht
und eine herzensangelegenheit
er war bereit das abkommen gegen
widerstände durchzusetzen
auch gegen widerstände im damaligen
deutschen bundestag
adenauer wusste die mehrheit der
deutschen war damals nicht bereit die
wahrheit zu hören das luxemburger
abkommen wurde es schweigend
unterzeichnet
wir eröffnen heute auch im deutschen
bundestag eine ausstellung die sich
diesem abkommen widmet sie zeigt die
kontrovers die deutschen zahlungen auch
in israel waren auch wie zwiespältig sie
von den betroffenen empfunden wurden die
ausstellung wurde im auftrag des
bundesfinanzministers von der us- claims
konferenz und dem knesset museum
konzipiert allen beteiligten möchte ich
schon jetzt danke sagen im namen des
ganzen hauses
ich zitiere noch einmal moschee schareck
die weltgeschichte kennt kein beispiel
für den vernichtungsfeldzug den das
nationalsozialistische deutschland gegen
das jüdische volk geführt hat es ist
keine schöne denkbar für die vernichtung
des lebens dieser millionen von
unschuldigen diese worte vor 70 jahren
sie wurden nicht ausgesprochen für uns
heute unvorstellbar wir übernehmen heute
die verantwortung für die deutschen
verbrechen
dieser einsicht hat sich erst im laufe
der jahrzehnte und gegen starke
widerstände durchgesetzt
wir verdanken sie unter anderem der
arbeit der gedenk und erinnerungsstätte
und vor allem dem engagement vieler
opfer von einst die die kraft gefunden
haben über ihre erlebnisse zu sprechen
so wie die auschwitz-überlebende eva dp
she die gemeinsam heute auch mit ihrer
enkelin an der heutigen
ausstellungseröffnung teilnehmen
sehr geehrte frau peggy herzlich
willkommen im deutschen bundestag
deutschland kann nicht wiedergutmachen
was nie mehr gutzumachen ist der
millionenfache mord an den europäischen
juden
umso mehr müssen wir die erinnerung an
die opfer wach halten und sie auch an
künftige generationen weitergeben
deswegen freut es mich auf der tribüne
auch viele jungen menschen begrüßen zu
können die sich für ein gedenken und
gegen antisemitismus engagieren
um es noch einmal sehr deutlich zu
betonen aus der vergangenheit folgt für
uns deutsche die verantwortung auch für
die gegenwart
jüdinnen und juden müssen in deutschland
sicher sein deutsche juden israelische
juden juden aus aller welt es ist
zutiefst schmerzhaft wenn wir diesem
anspruch nicht gerecht werden
so wie bei dem attentat auf die
israelische olympiamannschaft in münchen
an dessen opfer wir gestern erinnert
haben auch ich möchte sie herr präsident
und angehörige der opfer und vergebung
für die fehler und versäumnisse
deutschlands von
1972 und den quälenden jahrzehnten
danach bitten
ich bin froh dass die bundesregierung
und die angehörigen der opfer eine
einigung gefunden haben keine
entschädigungszahlung kann diese morde
ungeschehen machen oder die tiefen
wunden der angehörigen heilen aber diese
entschädigung bedeutet eine anerkennung
ihres leids 50 jahre nach dem
entsetzlichen attentat liegt darin zwar
ein spätes aber ein wichtiges zeichen
der verantwortung und es ist wichtig
dass die geschehnisse von damals
untersucht und aufgearbeitet werden auch
heute gibt es hass der sich gegen juden
und gegen israel gerichtet
es ist eine schande dass jüdische oder
israelische einrichtungen nur unter
polizeischutz sicher sind dass auf
demonstrationen gegen israel gehetzt
wird das in sozialen netzwerken israel
der tod gewünscht wird wir alle müssen
entschieden gegen diesen hass und diese
hetze vorgehen mit allen mitteln die uns
zur verfügung stehen
antisemitische taten kommen nicht aus
dem nichts sie werden auch möglich durch
wegsehen durch falsch verstandene
toleranz durch selbstgewissheit
antisemitismus ist nicht nur ein problem
der vergangenheit nicht nur ein problem
der anderen der extremisten
antisemitismus ist mitten unter uns in
der mitte der gesellschaft
in allen form entschieden
entgegenzutreten ist unser aller
verpflichtung
hinzu kommt antisemitismus ist subtiler
geworden es zeigt sich in neuen formen
die die alte judenfeindschaft auf dem
heutigen staates israel übertragen
getarnt als israelkritik gibt es
antisemitismus auch bei jenen die sich
im dienst einer guten sache sehen dem
antisemitismus darf kein forum geboten
werden nirgendwo auf der welt und erst
recht nicht bei uns in deutschland
dies gilt übrigens genauso für jeden
versuch die einzigartigkeit des
holocaust zu relativieren
herr präsident
deutschland steht fest an der seite
israels
israels sicherheit ist für deutschlands
außenpolitik eine verpflichtung
deutschland und israel verbinden
gemeinsame werte von freiheit und
demokratie
werte die in der ukraine auf brutale
weise verletzt werden es ist
unerträglich dass jeden tag menschen in
einem angriffskrieg leiden vertrieben
werden oder sogar sterben müssen
darunter auch holocaust-überlebende
deutschlands beziehungen zu israel
werden immer von der vergangenheit
geprägt sein es ist oft gefragt worden
können die beziehungen zwischen
deutschen und israelis normal sein eine
mehrheit in beiden ländern bejaht das
mittlerweile für viele deutsche ist
israel längst eine herzensangelegenheit
sie sind fasziniert von seinem
unternehmergeist seinem technologischen
know how von israels kunst und
kulturlandschaft und lebenswandel und
vor allem von seinen menschen zwischen
unseren ländern gibt es einen regen
austausch und es ist wichtig dass damals
möglichst viele menschen auch daran
teilnehmen
auch jene die nicht studieren in
internationalen unternehmen arbeiten
oder sich privat lange flugreisen
leisten können partnerschaften zwischen
betrieben können helfen begegnungen
möglich zu machen
der bundestag profitiert seit vielen
jahren von einem regelmäßigen austausch
mit der knesset ich würde es auch
begrüßen wenn es uns gemeinsam gelingt
ein israel deutsch israelisches
jugendwerk einzurichten zumindest hätte
ich mich dafür einsetzen
wir brauchen die persönliche begegnung
für ein tiefgreifendes und auch
nachhaltiges verständnis füreinander
35 jahre nach dem luxemburger abkommen
im jahr 1987 besuchte zum ersten mal ein
israelischer präsident deutschland er
war auch hier im reichstagsgebäude zu
gast damals stand die mauer noch in
sichtweite in seiner berliner rede
sprach dem herzog von einer ich zitiere
unsichtbare mauer zwischen unseren
beiden völkern einer mauer vor der wir
nur schweigend stehen können zitat ende
der präsident ihr vater war der erste
präsident israels der das
reichstagsgebäude aufsuchte sie sind der
fünfte israelische präsident der vor
diesem deutschen bundes bundestag heute
das wort ergreift so unglaubliches ihrem
vater erschien es ist uns gelungen die
mauer des schweigens abzutragen für uns
deutsche ist es ein geschenk
israelis und deutsche sprechen
miteinander über die zutiefst
schmerzhafte vergangenheit aber auch
über die gemeinsame hoffnungsvolle
zukunft
[Applaus]
die
jüdischen gemeinden in deutschland aber
ich schon die erste kreuzzug auf
die jüdischen gemeinden so genannten
kassel russen und ausgelagert gestürzt
und trauernd zurück
des traums wahr kann beginnen hier in
deutschland
des gedenkens
der jüdischen gebetet
und es gibt
bis zum tod begleitet und theologischen
jahres geworden
die sich das jüdische volk an gott mit
der absicht
das gedenken zu übertragen
die wir nicht vergessen können
des staates ist des jüdischen volkes
meine ansprache an sie mit dem
messcontainer erfuhr dass ich dem
seligen andenken unserer brüder und
schwestern die von den nazis und ihren
helfern getötet niedergemetzelt
vernichtet
bitte erheben sie sich für das chorgebet
ich denke gott der seelen unserer brüder
und schwestern des jüdischen volkes
opfern der shoah und ihre helden
der sechs millionen seelen des jüdischen
volkes
die getötet ermordet erdrosselt lebendig
begraben wurden in der heiligen
gemeinden die zerstört wurden
möge gott ihres opfers gedenken
zusammen mit den opfern alle anderen
heiligen des jüdischen volkes und ihre
helden seiner zeit ihrer im leben wie im
tod geliebt sanften und die getrennten
sehen
nehmen sie platz
verehrter präsident der bundesrepublik
deutschland mein guter freund
frank walter steinmeier
und seine gemahlin frei gebieten bender
unter bundeskanzler
vielen dank für ihre bewegenden und
verehrter präsident des bundesrates herr
bodo ramelow
verehrter vorsitzende des
bundesverfassungsgerichts dass stefan
herbert
liebl führungspersönlichkeiten
aus allen lebensbereichen deutschlands
meine damen und herren ich stehe heute
vor ihnen stehe jedoch nicht alleine
hier ich stehe hier als entsandte ich
stehe hier als präsident des staates
israel der souveränen demokratischen
nationalstaat des jüdischen volkes der
verwirklichung der gebete zahlreicher
generationen ich stehe hier als stolzer
sohn des jüdischen volkes
als vertreter der neuen generation von
rabbiner sehr molly sagt hillmann der in
deutschland als gemeinderat votierte er
selbst war nachfahre von rabbiner risken
katzenelnbogen rabbiner von hamburg und
der umliegenden gemeinden
stehe hier als staatspräsident begleitet
von träumen und krisen
schmerz und heilung
zerstörung und unabhängigkeit die
miteinander verknüpft sind vor allem
jedoch stehe ich vor ihnen versehen mit
einem gebot einem gebot
dass neben den zehn geboten und liebe
deinen nächsten wie dich selbst
vielleicht das höchste biblische gebot
darstellt das moralische und auch am
stärksten verpflichtende gut für jeden
einzelnen juden gedenken
die jüdische nation ist eine nation des
erinnern das gedenken will mit einen
grundlegenden
unabdingbaren bestandteil unserer
identität wenn ich dem nach deutschem
boden betrete kann ich der erinnerung
nicht entweichen ich nehme das foto
eines volkes aus meinem rucksack in ihm
befinden sich
viel davon gipfeln
bilder von abgründen
damit aufbauen möchte ich mit ihnen hier
und heute von der vergangenheit und von
der zukunft sprechen
ich zitiere auf meinem tisch liegt ein
stein darauf steht ein
dreieckiges bruchstück von einem
jüdischen friedhof
vor etwa 1000 jahren zerstört in der
stadt in der ich geboren wurde ein
einziges wort armen tief in den stein
ein geheimes sind armen hartmut
endgültig teil des zeugnisses über alles
was ihr gewesen und nie mehr sein wird
armen weich und melodisch wie bei einem
gebet armen und haben würde es so sein
ende des tals diese worte schrieb der
israelische dichter der jerusalemer mich
geboren vor der im bayrischen würzburg
als ludwig pfeiffer
sie erwecken den eindruck er wolle mit
seinen worten vorsichtig zwischen stolz
und schmerz vergangenheit in diesem land
bewilligt und die kluft überbrücken die
sich zwischen dem land seiner geburt und
seinem heimatland aufgeteilt
deutschland war deren hunderten und
tausenden von jahren eine prächtige
heimstatt für unser vor eine gemütliche
rheinstadt gut und
eine heimstatt in der sich das judentum
mit einer vielfalt entwickelte in
religion kultur
politik wissenschaft und vielen anderen
bereichen
in deutschland genießen die führenden
rabbinern die zu den bedeutendsten den
einflussreichsten in der geschichte
unseres volkes gehören hier entwickelte
sich die persönlichkeit von rabbiner
shlomo attraktiver er gilt als der
bedeutendste kommentare von bibel und
talmud
als
zurück rabbiner samsung raphael hirsch
und berlins wie hoffmann angehörige der
letzten generation
deutschland war die heimat herausragende
persönlichkeiten überreicht die
jüdischen kultur des jüdischen geistes
technischen wissenschaften dosis mendels
und geiger bis zur long doch lebt man
songs und gershom scholem
ehrlich bis emmy noether von wind und
auerbach und weil
else lasker schüler
hier müssen wir auch die pioniere der
sozialarbeit benennen
rosenblüt natürlich auch die
einflussreichen zionisten früher die in
deutschland angeflogen und sich hier
entwickelten unter anderem rabin
erzählerisch kalisch
moses hesse war und viele viele mehr in
allen bereichen des lebens
sie wurden alle hier geboren sie alle
wurden erzogen ausgebildet ihre
persönlichkeiten bei dir geformt sie
leisteten ihren beitrag zum aufschwung
des judentums sie leisteten ihren
beitrag zum aufschwung deutschlands
daher ist dieses land ihr land im
innersten und tiefsten dna meines volkes
verankert
aber meine damen und herren das ist kein
geheimnis dieses land deutschland war
der ort an dem die größten gräueltaten
wie das jüdische volk die gesamte
menschheit im laufe der geschichte zu
erdulden hatten angefangen mit
programmen aufständen wasser kommen
zerstörung ganzer jüdischer gemeinden
die in den vergangenen tausend jahren
immer wieder auftraten
bis zum tiefsten abgrund der geschichte
des menschlichen zusammenlebens der
shoah
die geschichte der menschheit kennt kein
beispiel für die von den nazis und ihren
helfern begeben und taten zur
vernichtung des jüdischen volkes
nie war ein land die nazi deutschland es
war
verantwortlich für den verlust jeglicher
menschlichkeit
jegliche barmherzigkeit
verantwortlich für die absicht mit so
unerbitterliche grausamkeit ein ganzes
volk auszulöschen
mein vater seligen andenken der sechste
präsident des staates israel sein herz
gehörte zu den befehlshabern die die
todeslager in deutschland kosten klauen
des nazi raubtiers befreiten ich werde
nie vergessen mit welchen worten das
grauen beschrieb dass ich vor ihm
auftaucht den gedanken gestand die
menschlichen skelette in gestreifter
häftlingskleidung die leichenberge woche
die zerstörung die hölle auf erden
wie sie es vorhin erwähnten fahrbahn ist
ex-präsident in den jahren 1987 reiste
er zum ersten mal
als israelischer staatspräsident nach
deutschland er begann seinen besuch im
todeslager bergen belsen
vier jahrzehnte nachdem es zum letzten
mal besucht hatte
in seinem besuch sprach herr folgende
worte ich zitiere kein vergeben bringe
ich und kein vergessen nur die toten
haben das recht zu vergeben
die toten haben das recht zu vergeben
die lebenden haben kein recht zu
vergessen das sagt er in seinem
testament
dass ich heute hier in meinem herzen
tragen
35 jahre sind vergangen in wenigen
stunden werde ich in meinem einen
staatsbesuch in bergen belsen hat
schließen ich möchte seine worte hier
wiederholen vor ihnen den vertretern des
deutschen volkes aus allen fraktionen
dieses hauses ich erkläre das jüdische
volk vergisst nicht
und nicht nur aufgrund unserer pflicht
den generationen der vergangenheit
gegenüber sondern aufgrund unserer
verpflichtung gegenüber den generationen
der zukunft
es ist nicht leicht
die auseinandersetzung mit dem gedenken
erschüttert sie ist von ihrem wesen her
komplex sie ist komplex hart und
schmerzhaft für die deutschen da es
immer menschen geben wird die alles
verleugnen die sich als angeklagte
frühere die ganz einfach die
vergangenheit ruhen lassen wollen auf
eine ganz andere art und weise ist sie
auch in israel komplex hart und
schmerzvoll es wollen oder nicht
das andenken an die shoah bildet einen
grundlegenden teil unserer nationalen
identität ein volk zu dessen
historischen gedenken so fürchterlich
unmögliche erfahrungen tiefsten abgründe
gehören ist kein volk wie jedes andere
trotz allem meine damen und herren auch
wenn wir uns auf den wegen des gedenkens
nicht begegnen können müssen wir uns im
umfeld der bedeutung geben dem gedanken
denken bedeutung vermachen
das bedeutet das gedenken als
verpflichtung als moralische auflage als
verantwortung zu sehen die vergangenheit
kann man nicht überbrücken die zukunft
jedoch gehört uns sie bringt eine große
verantwortung in sich daher muss sie uns
beiden gehören
und ihnen denn nur so
gemeinsam können wir dem gedenken
bedeutung verleihen
nur durch die begegnung die vertiefung
der beziehungen die hartnäckige
gegenseitige verpflichtung zur freiheit
zur menschlichkeit zur demokratie
neben einem beständigen treuegelöbnis
für die freiheit und sicherheit des
staates israel und das wohlergehen des
jüdischen volkes
zwischen beiden völkern die bedeutung
des gedenkens werden sie als beispiel
für die ganze menschheit gelten
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren
die geschichte verbindet das jüdische
volk und den staat israel
auf unabdingbare art und
eine verbindung des gedenkens der
bedeutung die auf den ebenen der
vergangenheit der gegenwart und der
zukunft ihren ausflug geben muss auf der
ebene der vergangenheit wir müssen
weiterhin lehren und erlernen
weiterhin ohne einschränkung und furcht
erforschen die wirklichkeit schonungslos
betrachten mit allen kräften gegen die
holocaust leugnung ankämpfen die
faktoren besprechen und zur shoah für
jeden stein umdrehen versuchen zu
verstehen was unfassbar ist
auf der ebene der gegen wird die
hauptaufgabe die uns tagtäglich von
morgens bis abends verpflichtet die hass
verbreitenden stimme nicht zu ignorieren
sollen sie im netz zum sozialen
netzwerken auf der straße oder in den
politischen machtzentren wir müssen
antisemitismus und rassismus den kampf
ansagen entschieden
eindeutig kompromisslos dem weg suchen
den wir gemeinsam beschreiten
den weg suchen den wir gemeinsam
beschreiten
ausgerichtet auf die werte des friedens
der gerechtigkeit des gegenseitigen
respekts der toleranz und der
partnerschaft
auf der ebene der zukunft meine damen
und herren bin ich der meinung dass die
uns auferlegte verpflichtung der zukunft
gegenüber auch ein wirkliches privileg
bedeutet die partnerschaft zwischen
israel und deutschland ist in der ganzen
welt bekannt es ist unsere aufgabe sie
zur erreichung einer strahlenden zukunft
weiter zu vertiefen zu entwickeln nicht
nur für unsere länder sondern für die
ganze welt
die nato staat israel ist heute ein
anstieg von wieder aufbau von erfolg von
überragendem beitrag an die menschheit
im bereich der kultur der medizin der
akademischen welt der wissenschaft und
vielen weiteren bereichen
israel hat im laufe der jahre in den
verschiedensten sektoren mit
europäischen ländern starke
partnerschaften aufgebaut
stadt beteiligt sich an bestrebungen
die krise zu lösen unter anderem die
klimakrise
ein land eine große rolle die zum umgang
mit dieser krise beitragen und zur
entwicklung von mobilen die nahen osten
hat sich israels und treibenden motor in
der entwicklung von partnerschaften in
der gesamten region entwickelt die
abraham abkommen folgen den vorherigen
friedens ab
normalisierung dialogen und annährung
erlauben es gute nachbarschaft
beziehungen
erfolg und nie dagewesenes wachstum in
unserer region aufzunehmen
[Musik]
die haben wir kritik gefürchtet ihn
haben wir kritik unterbunden eines
werden wir von unseren kritikern jedoch
immer verlangen alles auf die garching
zu prüfen israel streckt seine hand zum
frieden auf das ist die hässliche und
tiefen verbindungen mit einigen unserer
nachbarn sind war das gilt auch für die
große bedeutung die sich auf die gesamte
region er steckt auch das ist die
wahrheit seit eh und je steht israel und
der wird es auch weiterhin tun oder
nachbarliche beziehungen mit und frieden
mit allen staaten und völker des nahen
ostens
dieses beschrieben wird auch weiterhin
das gilt selbstverständlich auch für
unsere palästinensischen nachbarn dies
ist ein von hoffnung und glauben
getragen dass wir nie aufgeben
aufgegeben haben dass sie auch in
zukunft nicht aufgeben werden es
verpflichtet uns und auch die
palästinenser der realität in die augen
zu sehen und alle anstrengungen zu
unternehmen sie zum guten zu wenden
[Applaus]
unsere petition sich nachbar müssen
zuallererst den terror bekämpfen und ihn
sofort einstellen es gestern haben wir
und das präsidenten steinmeier und ich
mit den angehörigen über opfern und mit
israelischen und deutschen
führungspersönlichkeiten den fünfzigsten
jahrestag des auf deutschen boden
erfolgten fürchterlichen massakers bei
dem elf israelische sportler ermordet
wurden die an den olympischen spielen
1972 in münchen teilnehmen wollten die
palästinensischen terrororganisation
tragen die verantwortung für diesen
abscheulich für diese abscheulichen
morde ein verbrechen das nicht nur die
grundlegenden werte der menschenwürde
und der unversehrtheit des lebens traf
sondern auch den sport verseuchen und
insbesondere den geist der olympischen
spiele das gilt auch für die
verantwortung für weitere nicht weniger
entsetzliche terrorakte die seitdem und
bis zum heutigen tage verlegt werden aus
diesem anlass
möchte ich ihnen herr bundespräsident
kanzler chance und der bundesrepublik
für die bibel und die bayerische
regierung nicht die bedingungen die die
verständigung mit den angehörigen der
opfer ermöglicht haben in ihrem kern
verankert ist die übernahme der
verantwortung die verantwortung für eine
objektive historische untersuchung und
eine gewisse linderung des schmerzes für
die angehörigen zu den furchtbaren
schmerz bis ans ende ihrer tage in sich
tragen werden
ich danke ihnen für die bewegende
zeremonie die gestern in münchen statt
wann mit dem typischen verwenden und mit
jungen menschen aus israel und deutschen
und natürlich auch mit den trauer
familien meine damen und herren
israel ist teil der internationalen
bestrebungen die radikalen kräfte
aufzuhalten die terror trauer und
zerstörung verboten und jeden dieser
erde
auch in unserer generation zu unserer
zeit
bedrohen düstere hasserfüllte vom iran
angeführte kräfte nicht nur den staat
israel nicht nur das gleichgewicht im
nahen osten sondern die gesamte welt von
hier aus von dieser wichtigen bühne in
berlin aus rufe ich die völkerfamilie
dazu auf entschieden und hart gegen den
iran und seine pläne zur entwicklung von
kernwaffen vorzugehen
massenvernichtungswaffen in den händen
eines mitgliedsstaates der tagtäglich
zur vernichtung eines anderen
mitgliedsstaates aufruft das ist
unannehmbar
[Applaus]
handlungen zur vernichtung des staates
israel sind unannehmbar
die vorgaben müssen ganz eindeutig sein
wer die shoa leugnet er aus hass und
aggression handelt der die
daseinsberechtigung des staates israel
bedroht hat keinen anspruch auf die
unterzeichnung und vertrieb verträgen
die nur bestärken hat kein anrecht auf
vergünstigungen oder gelder hat kein auf
gar keinen fall anrecht auf zugestellt
müsse die internationale
staatengemeinschaft muss sich auf die
richtige seite der geschichte stellen
klare forderungen artikulieren scharf
notwendiges aktionen auferlegen eine
undurchdringliche mauer auf beim
zwischen dem iran und nuklearen
fähigkeiten zur handlung stand halt
nicht aufgeben der staat israel wird
sich verteidigen und mit allen mitteln
gegen die bedrohung des staates seine
bürger angriffe nicht wofür die ganze
welt auf nicht tatenlos zuzuschauen
[Applaus]
das teilte vertreter des volkes
deutschland und das deutsche volk haben
ihr land und ihre gesellschaft nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg auf bewundernswerte
und inspirierende weise wieder aufgebaut
deutschland hat sich einen namen gemacht
sich zu einem wirtschafts und
sicherheitsbereich führenden und
verantwortlichen großmarkt entwickelt
einem ottomotor von geist und kultur
dem initiator eines nie gekannten
aufschwungs in europa und der ganzen
welt
deutschland ist eine führende kraft und
eine bedeutende kraft in europa und in
der nato
gerade jetzt wird das besonders
offensichtlich bei der unterstützung der
unversehrtheit und des friedens der
ukraine ich bin davon überzeugt dass
deutschland eine führende rolle stehen
wird in der lösung dieser furchtbaren
tag hatte tragödie die das ukrainische
volk betrifft wir alle wünschen eine
möglichst schnelle beendigung seines
lebens und die rückkehr der stabilität
des friedens für die ukraine und ganz
europa
[Applaus]
die bahnbrechenden errungenschaften im
sozial versorgungsbereich beruhe auf
einer fortschrittlichen welt
entscheidung der beitrag zur
gleichberechtigung
die sorge um die schwachen der aufbau
einer beeindruckenden stützenden und
würde von infrastruktur für bedürftige
bilden einen rahmen der menschlichkeit
und der würde des menschen
beispielgebend für ganz europa das in
der ganzen welt geschätzt wird
der ehrenwerte status den das
demokratische deutschland in der
völkerfamilie genießt der ist zu einem
der wichtigsten anführer freien welt
werden ließ
beruht auf erfolg vor allem auf der
verpflichtung der vergangenheit
gegenüber aber nicht in geringem maße
der zukunft der menschheit deutsch und
hat bewiesen und beweist es weiterhin
dass es der erinnerungskultur und dem
gedenken erhebliche anstrengungen regnet
gleichzeitig setzte sich intensiv ein im
bereich der innovation des
unternehmertums der wissenschaft der
technologie forschung und vielem mehr in
allen bereichen von denen unsere zukunft
als menschheit abhängt der staat israel
ist stolz auf seine partnerschaft mit
deutschland und weiß die tiefe
freundschaft
das mutige bündnis dass zwischen unseren
ländern
geschlossen wurde und dem deutschen
beitrag zur sicherheit und zum erfolg
israels sehr zu schätzen ich bin der
festen überzeugung dass unsere
gemeinsamen werte
die tiefe freundschaft zwischen unseren
ländern
beitragen wird zur festigung unserer
freundschaft unserer partnerschaft zur
fortsetzung des weges den israel und
deutschland
gemeinsam beschreiten
seite an seite hand in hand auf eine
erfolgreiche hoffnungsträchtigen zukunft
hin
meine damen und herren
der israelische dichter den ich zu
beginn meiner worte zitierte jehuda
amichai dessen name aus der verbindung
der satz komponenten zusammengesetzt ist
herr armen stelle mein volk lebt
schließt du dem gesicht gedichts band in
dem er noch einmal den stein auf seinem
schreibtisch in jerusalem anspricht den
stein aus einem grabstein in seiner
geburtsstadt in deutschland
ich möchte zum abschluss meiner worte
hier heute noch einmal aus einem gedicht
zitieren und die hoffnung aussprechen
dass seine worte die grundlage für
unsere weitere partnerschaft bilden die
von der vergangenheit und der zukunft
genährt wird hier seine worte
dieser stein auf meinem schreibtisch
schenkt mir ruhe ein stein der wahrheit
unverrückbar
weiser als alle steine der weißen stein
von zerbrochenen grabstein und doch ganz
wien nur etwas sein kann stein des
zeugnisses über alles was hier gewesen
[Musik]
alles was je sein wird
einstein des armes und der liebe amen
amen
möge es so sein
standing ovations im deutschen bundestag
zu den israelischen staatspräsidenten
den sat herzog
während seiner rede hatte es immer
wieder zwischenapplaus gegeben wir sehen
unter den geladenen gästen direkt neben
dem bundespräsidenten frank walter
steinmeier den herzog auch mehrfach als
seinen freund bezeichnet hat ja in
seiner rede ging es klar noch mal um das
gedenken allerdings hat er auch seinen
blick in die zukunft gerichtet im werk
herzog und angesichts der konflikte und
kriege in dieser welt für frieden
geworben auch die bedrohung des staates
israel natürlich angesprochen
auf der agenda steht jetzt noch ein
gespräch mit der bundestags präsidentin
bärbel bas das war's zunächst mal aus
dem deutschen bundestag von uns wir
melden uns dann um viertel nach zehn mit
unserer vorberichterstattung von dort
wieder und gehen dann natürlich in die
haushaltsdebatte hier im studio in bonn
aber zunächst einmal nach großbritannien
denn da steht die neue fest list ost bis
dato außenministerin boris johnson und
wird so neue premierministerin gewählt
von den tory parteimitgliedern dem
britischen volk muss sich die 47 jährige
erst 20 24 in zwei jahren zur wahl
stellen heute erstmal die begegnung mit
der königin lässt rast die